good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast and happy hump
day that's right it's Wednesday a very
kind of I would say weekly holiday here
at the toast it is a weekly holiday and
the words of the snitch this morning why
isn't it Thursday you know this week has
really been [__] me up yesterday I
thought it was Wednesday it's so funny
how that's like a universal experience
not just like a personal like yeah my
week was kind of weird because like I
flew home on a Tuesday so I get why my
you know Vibes are off but how are my
vibes matching everyone else's yeah my
week is thrown off too I don't know what
day of the week it is and then all of a
sudden it'll be the end of the week and
I'll be like that was quick
but that's so life like how is it on a
Tuesday and then Friday comes oh my God
we literally have the same conversation
every morning but then Friday comes and
we're like that like wasn't so bad yeah
we made it we did it and the thing how
crazy was this week what's so crazy
what's so crazy tell me to blow your
mind okay so every single week is the
same amount it's the same length
but like it's not even when we have a
short week like there was still a Monday
no that's kind of what's so crazy about
life is you know nothing in life is
guaranteed and there's so much
uncertainty in life but Monday Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Friday Saturday
Sunday is really always there for us and
we should kind of find peace in that
instead of fighting it you know we
should embrace it yeah and like it's
just crazy how the weeks could feel so
different but they are all exactly the
same
at the end of the day I think that
that's a really good message just for
Humanity like we could feel so different
from one another but we are the same
not only that it's a good message for
life like life can feel so crazy so
chaotic so uncertain but
Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday
Saturday Sunday is always there for you
yeah I don't know that they're there for
you but like you can always count on
tomorrow
well yeah well actually you can't count
on tomorrow which is why you should live
today to the fullest yeah maybe you
can't but like there will be a tomorrow
with or without whether you're here or
not
stop that's funny
um so it's Wednesday all of that to say
it is Wednesday feeling not totally like
a Wednesday but we're gonna make it feel
like a Wednesday because we have deer
toasters
let me continue even though we wish it
was Thursday and like we feel like it
should be at least it's on Tuesday
that's true
so there's glory in all of it we're
making our way through the week and you
know there's actually a lot going on pop
culture why is like so many more updates
from this lizzo thing that to be a
toaster it's a good day because we have
lots to discuss it's also Wednesday
which means we do our weekly advice
segment dear taoisters so I don't feel
like if you're listening to the toast
you really have anything to complain
about like put that in perspective you
know there are weeks where you know
we're talking about like the new Wendy's
collab like we have seen Joker times
people don't don't [__] on the new
Wendy's collab
I wasn't because you know what the
Wendy's Club is always there for us when
no one else much like old days of the
week you can always count on a good food
news collab when the celebrities are
doing nothing
no it's true and like for for something
to be popping off during August which is
a notoriously slow month for celebrities
I just think it's important that we take
a moment and you know acknowledge that
yeah
acknowledged
consider it acknowledged moving on how
are you
I'm amazing you know after not sleeping
in my own bed for like a week getting my
first night back in my own bed I say
this all the time but like
if there were like the world's leading
sleep scientists who all got together
and studied my sleep for a year my
habits my patterns my dreams like they
all studied everything about my sleep
patterns for like let's say 10 years and
then they built with the world's leading
Engineers a bed perfectly tailored to my
every sleep need
I'm telling you that bed wouldn't be as
good as my current bed like my current
bed is everything to me
what is good about your bed
nothing it's just my bed oh okay cool
you know it's like even the world's best
bed in the world it's not my bed yeah
is your bed is like
whatever science yeah no but like I said
it's not like there's anything it's not
like you have you know a ducks on a
mattress you're not listening that's not
what I'm saying it's because it's mine
by Kelly Clarkson
it's Mine by Taylor Swift
oh cause mine is Mine by Kelly Clarkson
wait I fell into like this weird Kelly
Clarkson rabbit hole on Tick Tock last
night
you saw that she did her residence she
started her residency in Vegas and she's
like making news singing all about her
ex and her x-man's dad yeah and she did
abcdefu yes so her x-man's dad of course
we all know but for those who don't was
um dating rebuff or married I think to
Reba for a really long time and he also
ended up being like a a you know grifter
taking things from Reba and Kelly and
Reba have like solidarity with one
another
um but I guess like Kelly's
x-man's dad has a new girlfriend and
she's been like leaving hate comments on
Kelly Clarkson's Instagram she's like
five followers I think she's private but
like somebody found it and she was like
you're really not taking the high road
Kelly like no class coming for Kelly
because of what Kelly's been singing
yeah well and she was commenting on the
video a b c d f u and your dad yeah she
changed the lyrics and Kelly's big mad
Kelly's big mad and I kind of love that
she's actually not taking the high road
and like you know very Kim Kardashian
like the father of my kids I will never
say and I respect that I really really
do but I also just love people you know
getting what's theirs yeah but it's
different when you say it in your art
versus yeah she has a talk show she
doesn't go off about her husband when
she did when she did her album press
tour like she did go there as you know
she went on radio Andy and Howard Stern
and she was being nice and I still don't
know what happened
that she just had to give him a lot of
money when they divorced but why did
they divorce
oh that that's true that I don't know
right like she talked and all the songs
like she talks about like you know I
hope someday someone does to you like
what you did to me
I don't know what he did
that's actually really true and I don't
think I should know
but also because
so I think she is trying to be artistic
and
talk about it and work through her
emotions without like spelling it out
you know like Kelsey ballerini on call
her daddy but Kelsea ballerini didn't
have kids with Morgan Evans so she was
able to say all that of course but I
just I think there's something to be
said for like you know divorce is so sad
and I feel like people talk about that
all the time but like the money part is
like infuriating and that's really
Kelly's Focus like she keeps saying that
he got half the ranch that she bought
him like she talks a lot about the
material items and I feel like that's a
very human response like especially for
like a woman who's worked her ass off
from being on like a talent show to
being one of the biggest stars in
Hollywood and you know the the highs and
lows that's come with that like I really
appreciate how she's really focusing on
the money because like I don't know how
people get [__] past that yeah yeah
like that's in [__] infuriating yeah
relatable Queen
100 percent
she's a woman of the people she is I'm
sad I'm not there in res in Vegas to see
her
doing her thing I feel like we've truly
come full circle because the first thing
ever that got canceled during the
pandemic that we had tickets to was
Kelly's residency we literally got the
best seats and now with inflation like I
actually think we had an amazing price
back then it felt like so much but in
this economy Penny's on the dollar
mm-hmm
and we had front row we had like a VIP
Booth with weight service and bottle
service oh my God we had like eight
tickets we were gonna bring the whole
family like I'm so upset no it was a
devastating loss it was huge for the
community yeah
I guess we'll just have to go next next
time if there is a next time Kelly so
predictable no one thing about Kelly
she's just getting started and I feel
like her album has like crazy legs like
it did really well I think it debuted
like number eight on Billboard but for
like the Gen Z kings and queens who
don't really know Kelly's story it's all
over Tick Tock like people are still
talking about it like I think her album
like is gonna get even bigger honestly I
love that even me I'm like a big Kelly
girl I like there was so much music and
so much happening in my life like I
didn't really sit down and listen to it
up until two weeks ago it's incredible
yeah I've I've listened to it in full a
few times but I haven't like plucked out
my favorite songs yet and added them to
my playlist
I have playing cowboy in the world wow
except for it's so good mine and me I
love those two but those were singles
yeah no it's it's really work of art
that and it's one of those things and it
reminds me a lot of like a Taylor Swift
album like the more you listen to it the
better it gets the deeper it gets it's
not like these you know kitschy pop
songs that you have to surface
exactly it's not surface lyrics it's not
giving surface whatsoever no Kelly
doesn't do anything at the surface no
and that's why like we waited so long
for this album and it it delivered in
every possible way mm-hmm
queen queen
but yeah so they all set to say Reba's
x-man's new girl is starting beef with
Kelly but like Kelly it's literally like
fan Behavior Kelly probably in her
thousands and thousands of comments
couldn't even see this irrelevant girl
if Kelly even spends time on her
Instagram which I follow her because I
love her but it's not the sort of
Instagram that feels you know self-run
it's giving social team yeah it is as it
should be Kelly's busy nothing wrong
with that she's a mother and you know
what like not everyone needs to be an
Instagram expert
like an authentic content creator no not
at all like her job is to make music
that speaks to millions of people and
she's amazing at it and host a talk show
that's really kind of changing the
landscape yeah and she's a judge on The
Voice sometimes right she's so busy
she's children she's the author she has
her furniture line she's got to make up
for the half a fortune she gave to her
ex-man yeah that was like in Jessica
Simpson's book when she had to give like
half of her earnings to Nick Lachey and
she was like but I'll make it back give
or take a billion
it was a final line of a chapter right
yep yep
yeah I told myself I'll make it back and
I did give or take a billion slain yeah
like at that time it probably felt like
all of her money going to Nick Lachey
but now she literally owns a billion
dollar like merchandise Empire like okay
Nick take it was probably like back then
like one or two million dollars there's
probably a couple million still hurts
but she made it back
right and that's what I was out to say
what I was saying about Kelly like it
hurts and not enough people talk about
the money they're always talking about
like the breaking down of a family yeah
I get it but like money's important too
yeah
like imagine just having to give up a
half
what about getting half
oh that's different that's definitely
different
um and if I found myself in a situation
where like I would be getting half like
you bet your ass had to be taking it I
would not be like a principled queen I'd
be like that's literally mine it's of
course also and I know this is like
people always yell at me for saying this
it's men and women it's different like a
woman taking half of a man's thing like
as you should it is it is very gendered
and also like typically not every
situation but typically the woman is the
primary care provider for the children
and makes the life and pays for the
school and does the house and the
groceries and and one gives up her
career to do that right so
it's just not the same no it's not the
same it's completely gendered and like a
man taking half of a woman yikes like
couldn't be me it's disgusting like it's
a humiliating yeah I agree but like a
woman yes Queen yeah
coin you earned it yeah you literally
worked for it
no problem with that you're never gonna
catch me finding a woman like judging a
woman for that ever no that's not even
like news no love that for you Camille
grammar love that for you yeah
it is what it is yeah so we could get
into the stories if you're feeling ready
I mean it'd truly be a pleasure we have
so much to do today it's probably it's
probably best that we do it's for the
best so without further adieu here are
the fast five stories that you need to
know
and very exciting we have a new sponsor
today's episode is brought to you by
Pillsbury so we all know and love
Pillsbury crescent rolls but for all of
our busy girlies here all of our mamas
did you know that Pillsbury crescents
can transform you know with a couple
delicious ingredients you can transform
the crescents from a side dish to a main
dish with Pillsbury crescents it's easy
as filling roll it fill roll bake please
your picky eaters and move on with your
evening so if you have kids who are
picky eaters or you know adults or a
sister yeah uh Pillsbury Crescent can
make a gorgeous dinner time recipe
um and they have great recipes on their
website so pepperoni pizza crescent
rolls chicken bacon ranch crescent rolls
ham and cheese crescent rolls and you
know if you've got a kosher eater just
take that pepperoni out and make a
gorgeous Pizza crescent roll a little
sauce a little sprinkle of cheese that
sounds like heaven you can find
Pillsbury in the dairy aisle
um so just you know do the most with
your Pillsbury crescent roll perfect for
dinner ideas dinner prep weeknight
recipes they're so easy you're busy your
kid is hungry head over to the dairy
aisle where you can find Pillsbury and
you can dinner prep in 30 minutes or
less it is a very picky eater pleasing
and you can find more weeknight dinner
recipes at pillsbury.com that's
p-i-l-l-s-b-u-r-y.com pillsbury.com just
do it you won't regret it they're
delicious you know it and get creative
girlfriend it'll be easy today's episode
is also brought to you by betterhelp so
sometimes in life we're faced with tough
choices and the path forward is not
always clear whether you're dealing with
decisions around your career
relationships personal things anything
therapy helps you stay connected to what
you really want while you navigate life
so you can move forward with confidence
and excitement and trusting yourself to
make decisions that align with your
values is like anything the more you
practice it the easier it gets and
that's where better help comes in if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
better help a try it's entirely online
it's designed to be convenient flexible
and suited to your schedule just fill
out a brief questionnaire to get matched
with a licensed therapist and switch
therapist anytime for no additional
charge there's so many fabulous things
about betterhelp I think one of the
great things is that if you started
therapy or you've been therapy for many
years you know that like it's very
common that the first or second or third
therapist that you work with might not
be a match for you it's like a very
personal personality thing and it can be
really awkward in real life like to
cancel and go to the office it's just
like weird but better help because it's
done entirely online if you want to
switch up therapists you can do that at
any time it's not awkward and then when
you find someone you love you can work
communicate with them in any way that
you're comfortable with whether that's
talking on the phone video chatting
texting whatever Medium you're most
comfortable with and feel that you can
be your most honest self with you can do
with better help
so let therapy be your map with better
help visit betterhelp.com toast today to
get 10 off your first month that's
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash toast betterhelp.com
t-o-a-s-t
thank you Claudia yeah well
um our first story a little more news in
the lizzo lawsuit including the fact
that Beyonce left lizzo's name out of
the lyrics of her song at the concert
last night amid this bombshell lawsuit
so Beyonce seemingly reacted to the
lawsuit brought against lizzo at her
concert on Tuesday night leaving lizzo's
name out of her lyrics while singing
Break My Soul in Foxboro Massachusetts
Beyonce repeated Badu in place of
lizzo's name originally the song lyrics
read Rosetta Tharp Santigold bestie
Smith Nina Simone Betty Davis Solange
Knowles badou lizzo Kelly roll instead
she said Badu Badu Badu Badu so she left
out lizzo's name but also it's worth
noting that Erica Badu actually kind of
like shaded Beyonce this week on
Instagram some things one it's Badoo and
two I saw people saying that but I
didn't think he was shady
um I didn't think it was like that
Shady like I guess they're wearing a
similar hat and then Erica tweeted like
I guess I'm everyone's stylist now right
like she's just patting herself on the
back for like being an inspiration like
I don't think that's crazy yeah I don't
think it's crazy I don't think it means
that like Beyonce should change that
lyric but it is just interesting that
she actually doubled down
on that and while taking out lizzo but
the the statement is but she also took
out Kelly she also took out Kelly Roland
so I kind of feel like maybe she just
flubbed the words like I feel like maybe
there's something here and maybe there's
not because I feel like like Beyonce's
not one to like give into public
pressure or anything you know
I don't know I think it's a little
deeper than that
I don't think she's loved the lyrics on
like her lead single from her most
recent album
yeah the timing is suspicious for sure
yeah
but the for me the interesting thing
about the lizzo lawsuit is like so much
happened yesterday after like the NBC
News dropped the you know the whole
lawsuit investigation is so many people
who've worked with lizzo kind of who
aren't a part of the lawsuit posted on
social media just corroborating it and
these are people who have like worked
deeply with her on tour there was you
know a costume designer a videographer
like a filmmaker yes someone said like
supposed to direct her documentary who
left after two weeks because like it was
the most toxic arrogant she called lizzo
out specifically like she is arrogant it
was definitely uh a bad day for lizzo
fans yesterday because lizzo hasn't
responded so now it's just all these
people speaking out on their experiences
with lizzo and all of them are negative
um just kind of reaffirming that like
classic celebrity Trope where like you
know front-facing is so different than
who they truly are and I feel like in
the age of the internet and social media
a lot of that doesn't happen anymore
because you really can't get away with
being a completely different person at
like restaurants in your private life
yeah because you'll get called out so I
feel like we haven't added something
like this in so long but it really
appears that like lizzo her public
Persona is like oh 180 for who she is in
real life which is just shocking I feel
like we haven't had a situation like
that in a while yeah also I feel like
what sometimes when stuff like this
happens a lot of people come out of the
woodwork and there's people speaking for
both sides like no I've worked with
lizzo she was amazing I haven't seen
anything like that yeah and we've only
seen the people who clearly worked with
her in a very official capacity and had
a terrible experience so much so that
they like took themselves out of the
equation but I'm sure it was a very big
job for them so I think
it all like just is very damning
and another update for when we were
talking yesterday about weight shaming
we were saying like there's obviously no
way lizzo was commenting on a dancer
gaining weight because that's her whole
brand
um and actually it has come out that it
was about a weight gain you know kind of
berating a dancer for not being able to
keep up and blaming it on the fact that
she's gained 10 pounds so it was like a
weight gain thing I feel like that's
like the most damning thing thus far the
banana vagina is the most scaring but
yeah that's crazy
right and I think that's like a really
like heartbreaking for a lot of people
who like really look up to lizzo
yeah I wonder if Beyonce knows lizzo or
like this was just she was just like a
lyric in her song because she's an icon
because personally or know who she is no
I'm sorry personally because it's like
if you know that she's not a great gal
then why is she in your song to begin
with
um if you didn't know if you don't know
her well enough to know what she's
actually like why is she in your song
I actually think that Beyonce doesn't
know lizzo personally enough to know
what she's like but like Beyonce's a
person in the world and can't deny and
the whole point of the lyric is like
listing off like iconic influential
black women and that is lizzo so like I
feel like Beyonce just you know surveyed
the culture and put lizzo in there
because up until yesterday lizzo really
was like a groundbreaking you know
really industry shifting Queen yeah
agreed I I think I'm actually so
surprised that she took her name out of
the lyric no I know that's like I'm so
surprised to the point where I actually
believe like maybe it was a lyric Club
yeah because I feel like she would I
don't know Beyonce personally either but
I just feel like she would require a
little more
critical thinking like like evidence
like you know if this is just these are
claims it's just getting started like
yeah people are saying really terrible
things but like you've seen the pendulum
swing back the other way sometimes like
it just seemed like very quick yes
that's what I was saying but I feel like
Beyonce would initially like always
stand with like another woman in the
business like I'm sure people have said
things about Beyonce that are not true
so I feel like if you know she was gonna
take the lyric out it would be like 100
confirmation not one day later or not
even one day that night yeah but
remember when Beyonce took that lyric
out of her song like the day her album
dropped I think she used the SP starzy
word was that Beyonce or was that lizzo
it was both so first it was lizzo it was
the big controversy with lizzo then
Beyonce's album came out and that word
was on a song and everyone was like oh
my God I can't believe she used that
word I I didn't think for one second she
was gonna do anything about it change it
and she changed it right after she put
out like this masterpiece she tweaked it
for that word so yeah yeah yeah
so she has like a recent track record of
kind of giving in to internet culture
pressure
yeah I don't know I just feel like
Beyonce's on tour literally the article
dropped yesterday morning she was
probably in soundcheck all day like how
the [__] is she finding out about this
like she's so
that kind of cut off from she doesn't
like a cell phone she's not scrolling
Twitter like that like unless she knows
some of the people who are not the
dancers but maybe like the filmmaker
um you know small world it is a small
world that music bubble that's
interesting
it's very interesting that she changed
it and it made it much bigger news
because if she had kept the lyric in I
don't think anybody from the show would
have been like she kept this lyric in
when lizzo's been accused of these
things because it was literally day one
it'll be interesting to see what she
does for the rest of her tour
I think the tour is over Beyonce sorry I
thought you're talking about Liz oh
sorry no like what is Beyonce going to
sing next weekend I need to know
yeah no that's a really good call first
of all and second of all another update
from the lizard thing I've been like I
fell into lizzo Tick Tock
um so one obviously like all the heat is
falling on lizzo but you know like
there's a lot of people like management
who create a toxic environment like that
and one of the people I think it was
like head of choreography or something
um who was named in the lawsuit as being
like one of the really toxic people
working there took to Instagram stories
and just like gave a it was like a 90
second video about how God is good and
she's so blessed like she's like I just
got off this amazing tour I'm home with
my family God is good God loves you this
is the sign you need God loves you I'm
like okay
yeah and thanks to the cast and crew
objection relevance yeah everyone worked
really hard on this tour thank you but
losing silence lizzo silence is
definitely really loud because she's not
the type of celebrity who like doesn't
use social media and only she's like
like borderline and influencer
especially on Tick Tock she posts like
five videos a day she's kind of like a
content creator and it's been really
good for her business but she's
um really active on social media so her
not saying anything yet it's been like a
whole day it's kind of crazy is she
posting other stuff no no no no no no
okay
I don't think the silence is actually I
think she might say something this is
becoming a very big story right I think
yesterday I was questioning I'm like is
this it had just dropped I'm like are
people gonna care
um but I think the allegations were so
egregious that it has become like an
enormous story and new things keep
coming out people keep speaking so she
really has no choice but to respond and
I'm sure she's limited because it's a
legal matter but at this point like the
court of public opinion is just as big
of a deal as like an actual court so she
has to say something yeah I think she'll
say I'm limited in what I can say but I
love my casting yeah I love my cast and
crew like I I would never want anyone to
feel anything less than on one of my
sets like I'm all about
positivity this and that and I hope you
know show you guys out there at my next
show
now this probably is a good segue into
our next story which I assume is coming
next but a lot of people are are calling
this you know Taylor Swift like you
speak against Taylor Swift and bad
things happen to you no there's a lot of
discourse on whether uh lizzo actually
did shade Taylor Swift and I have no
doubt that she did like multiple times
um and it's just funny well not funny
it's just ironic that like lizzo kind of
shaded Taylor Swift in defense of
Beyonce and Beyonce's out here dropping
her name from the lyrics that is so
funny yes our next story is about Taylor
Swift so we could talk about
um Taylor and lizzo and if you think
this is some sort of Karma and at the
time I I was like going off of the lizzo
that I thought I knew and I was like you
know she definitely doesn't want beef
with anyone she just like is like this
affable person who gets along with
everyone but now like if we're talking
about mean girl lizzo if that's who she
is she was definitely shading Taylor
by the way even when I thought lizzo was
like Queen of kindness like it was like
facts are facts like she literally she
was being so clearly talking about
Taylor multiple times and I had told you
I had a feeling that lizzo didn't like
Taylor Swift on that Sizzle live stream
where sizza was just kind of like
talking about how Taylor's like
wonderful and they have like you know a
lot of mutual respect for one another
and they have a good relationship and
lizard just sat on that Instagram like
completely silent didn't even say cool
like she made a face like I was like oh
there's something there and then these
last two recent times where she like
took that sign that girl's sign and
signed it where it was like I didn't go
to Taylor Swift so I could go to your
show like of all the signs you're gonna
pick up it's gonna be the one pitting
two women against another like we should
have known
I was trying to give the benefit of the
doubt you know some people do like some
actions can be misconstrued and
misunderstood true true but now it feels
like maybe it's congress with who she is
you love Congress and you also honorable
mention love affable which is such a
great word and every time you say it I'm
like yes that's the perfect word can you
give what's the actual definition of
affable likeable yeah gets along
friendly good-natured or easy to talk to
affable such a great word I gotta start
I've been using Congress like I need to
start getting affable in there Congress
is so good and so is incongruous
a hundred percent because what's the
opposite Jackie what's the opposite of
affable oh it wouldn't be like
non-affable it's ineffable is that a
word no
it was just unfriendly is the synonym
nasty
there are actually a ton of great words
for that nefarious how much time do you
have nefarious the best one the best one
let's get to the next story
um affable Taylor Swift has paid out 55
million dollars in bonuses to workers on
her hours tour so we talked about this a
little bit yesterday but we got the
number wrong and the real number I
thought that's nice of you it was me I
got the number wrong listen I'll help
I'll help carry your burdens and
celebrate your successes we do it
together
except like next time you [__] up don't
put that [__] on me like no it's where
are we here okay okay where are we here
at the toast it's good we are
um the wins are ours and the losses are
ours ain't that the truth but the real
story is actually much bigger than what
we touched on yesterday and worth a
mention in the past five today 100
Taylor Swift has doled out a total of 55
million dollars in bonuses to workers on
her eras tour as the American leg of her
tour wines to a close the songstress
paid out the sum to workers on the
lucrative Trek including backup dancers
rigging professionals sound technicians
catering personnel
and truck drivers
that she went top to bottom yeah to
everyone involved in the ongoing tour
insiders told people on Tuesday
I mean when you think about how much
money this tour has generated like over
a billion dollars like 55 sounds like so
much and it is so much no it's still she
can afford it she can of course she can
afford it and I'm sure in some way it's
a write-off but it's a lot even if the
tour generate a billion dollars like she
didn't make a billion dollars
there's a lot of things that need to be
paid this is it's expensive you know
there's commissions and whatnot it's
incredibly generous like when we thought
it was 5 million like that was a really
really nice
but you know like not that much to her
this is 11 fold it's a lot of money it's
almost
it's almost 20 of the generated money no
so I was trying to Google like how many
um
how many people does that include you
know
I have no idea
like I would say it's like maybe 100
hundreds
I don't know that includes dancers
backup singers truck drivers
um like camera riggers sound technician
sound technicians catering people
actually building the physical stage
that's like like I think it's more like
hundreds yeah but are there people who
work for the stadium that help her like
who's in her like I don't think those
people got these tips no only the people
that were people on the road with her
yeah people who work for stadiums who go
to like one specific show like uh ushers
and security no no I'm talking about but
people who work for the stadiums help
set up too no it's not just on the art I
don't think so I don't think so because
it's such a detailed thing like it's
something you literally need to be
trained in and do hundreds of times so I
think she has her own like production
people who physically come and set up
the stage got it okay so it's hundreds
of people and then like assistance yeah
it's definitely hundreds that's why the
number is so high yeah
that's crazy and we know for a fact that
she had given um truck drivers a hundred
thousand so I think we can assume like
everybody got around the same amount
right
um I don't think so
I guess like the most rigorous everyone
else is flying you know
I guess maybe that was the top of the
bonuses because I think the truck
drivers are probably working the most
hours but did you also see that video
I'm sure you saw of how many trucks it
takes to put on her show it was like
I didn't count but it looked like 30 40
trucks yeah
it's insane yeah I mean yeah she's
coming off looking really good this week
she's been looking really good this year
but especially in light of the Liz host
stuff and no in light of the lizzo stuff
and then it looks like a saint
it's been a very good like two years for
Taylor like so many of the people who
she publicly feuded with like having
their own downfalls like Kanye and then
like scooter bronze divorce like that's
why people say like you know Comfort
Taylor the world comes for you and now
if it seems as a lizzo has fallen into
that as well well that's why Taylor says
you know karma is her boyfriend
precisely karma is a God and she keeps
her side of the street clean
yes but I mean it's natural for everyone
to ebb and flow so I don't think it's
like
you know Taylor's hex honestly like
everyone's gonna she had a bunch of bad
years too yeah right everyone's gonna
have highs and lows in their
professional career and in their
personal lives like considering scooters
divorce as a win for Taylor like I
actually don't see it that way I agree I
agree because that's like a personal
like tragedy yeah I don't think that
Taylor was hoping they would get
divorced me neither like
whatever she's not an evil person and
these are the fans like this isn't what
Taylor said I think Taylor yeah no I
think Taylor wants would want like
professional retribution not a breakup
of a family like that doesn't help her
totally and Taylor herself is a child of
divorce I don't think she would wish out
on other children no
so it's like a fun fact a lot of people
don't know because her parents are like
always with her and they're always
together and it wasn't like it's it's
something that people currently find out
and are like wait her parents are
divorced because they always appear like
as a family unit and I don't think even
I knew that until like years after it
wasn't a story when it happened it's
just like a fun fact now how old was she
when it happened
let me tell you and does she have songs
about it no
she was old enough I think to understand
they divorced in 2011 which was 13 years
ago which would make her like 20. is
that like speak now
yeah it's a year after speak now
interesting
yeah
I mean who understands the trials and
tribulations of relationships better
than Taylor Swift
yeah
even though I feel like we've been
having this conversation that like
people whose parents get divorced when
they're kids it's actually like much
less of a trauma than it is when they're
like older yeah like I think a lot of
people they wait to get divorced for the
kids so that you don't like ruin their
childhood but then you kind of just like
shift the axis of their world when you
get divorced as it and they're adults
they're like Oh I thought I knew what a
relationship and love was like but you
guys didn't even like each other this
whole time
right and like when I think about our
parents divorce like I don't think of it
as like this Earth shifting it's like
tragedy it's not it's not like my trauma
like it is some people's trauma I think
it depends on a lot of factors age is
one of them but I think it's also just
like
you know maybe do you have siblings I
think that helps like you cannot feel
like so much pressure
um the way that your parents handle it
like if you've seen your parents sad
that makes you sad if you're seeing your
parents like better than ever you're
like hey
I think the parents really set the tone
that's true I think there's a lot but
age is a consideration yeah
are you ready for our next story what
number is this number three yes the
unlikely show of the summer is suits
have you seen this yes it's like killing
it on Netflix suits has set the record
for Library shows on streaming charts
this week it has even though this number
sounds big I don't know what it means
3.14 billion minutes viewed this week
minutes viewed is like the most random
obscure analytic no I know and that's
like just how many people are watching
it I know but that's what we're saying
about with the streamers and the strike
and the residuals they won't tell you
how many people are watching if they
give you these [__] minutes viewed
yeah but suits had the most minutes
viewed this week according to Nielsen
easiestly easily surpassing the previous
Mark of minutes viewed which was for
manifest which before it became a
Netflix original The Bear Went to number
two on minutes viewed but uh or number
three the witcher's number two whatever
but people are really shook because
everyone's kind of being introduced to
Suits right now which is the show that
we most of us know Meghan Markle from
and the last episode aired four years
ago but now there's kind of talk about
bringing it back since it's so popular
I'm just trying to do 3.5 billion
how many zeros is that one two three
nine one five six seven
no it would be nine zeros it would be
eight
because the point nine because the point
five yeah
so let's say how like what they're an
hour long
let's say people watch
two episodes
okay
so it's like a hundred minutes right why
would they only watch two episodes
everyone watches I'm just being
conservative no you're gonna be you're
gonna the numbers gonna be really big
okay okay hold on 35 one two three four
and also there's like a number of
seasons
okay so do they watch a whole last
season
I'm just trying to be conservative like
three points because I'm saying 3.5
billion minutes actually isn't a lot
yeah
I watch the whole season how many hours
is that divided by 60.
it's
I don't [__] know this is why they
don't want they want to keep us un
knowledgeable about their numbers
how much of Meghan markle's impact do
you think has to do with this I think
it's a definitely like a really good
show and I think everybody loves that
that guy Harvey's like hot but Meghan
markle's impact is undeniable 100
there's a curiosity like oh here say
there's this show this is the one that
Meghan Markle was on I think they might
start it because it's like oh that's
interesting and then they get hooked
because it is a good show and it's also
the perfect kind of like bingeable show
it has a number of Seasons it's not too
deep like that's what people like to
binge watch so yeah but I do think that
she has helped but now when they talk
about you know maybe we'll bring it back
because it's so popular now and there
are new fans the question is never does
Megan go back never
literally no she couldn't I don't think
she would the producer had said like
that it wasn't likely that she would but
but we know she's on good terms with a
lot of the casts because they came to
the wedding yeah
but that was like six years ago I love
that Gabriel mocked Jewish King oh he
plays Harvey and he's in my favorite
movie because I said so he plays out
like Jason mrazi type of musician who
Mandy Moore falls in love with I love
him like I should watch suits you should
wear suits and I think I definitely
straighten it because I think that's
where really people came to see her
Marco Sparkle so that when she was
announces dating and engaged to Prince
Harry like the people who knew her from
the show were not surprised yeah no
you're totally right I feel like Ben
would like it too maybe I will start
soon
I know Olivia and Margot both watched it
and loved it when they watched it when
it was on yeah they're the real ones a
hundred percent like they knew who
Meghan Markle was I didn't yeah and I
think overall this is good for Megan
they've had some bad press in the last
few months but I think like people like
watching her show and liking it and I
think she is a really good actress from
what I've seen her and she's a good
actress
um I think it must endear more people to
her so I think this is overall a good
thing a win for everybody I agree yeah
and win for content
uh-huh
I don't know in this you know strikey
times I don't know if we're looking for
a win for the streamers but it is it's
true
I I can't go back down this Rabbit Hole
of whether it's better for the trike if
I watch TV or if I don't yeah I actually
um I did read that it is good to support
the
like watched TV go see the movies
because it proves to Hollywood in the
studios and the streamers just how
valuable all the members of strike the
Sagar excuse me but you don't think it
might show it might they might take it
as like oh we're fine whether or not
they're promoting and working with us or
not or they're on strike the numbers are
the same okay I don't know that's a good
point that's why I said I can't go down
this Rabbit Hole again I'm not sure I'm
not sure I'll just read my Kindle yeah
are you ready for our next story yeah
Gwyneth Paltrow lists her Montecito
Guest House on Airbnb and she will have
dinner with the occupant so it's not as
exciting as it seems it's for one night
at least the group founder announced
that she is listing her Montecito
California Guest House on Airbnb she
wrote on Instagram loneliness is a human
condition but in the past few years
increased isolation and our lack of
community has made our lives even more
fragmented in order to make the world a
little less lonely she's inviting one
lucky fan and a guest of their choice
the opportunity to stay on her five
million dollar property she said while
we may begin as strangers I hope we'll
find connections and commonalities over
a delicious meal lay by the pool go on
one of my favorite hikes and of course
you'll have a bathroom stocked with my
favorite group products so this is a
partnership with Airbnb and it's a good
one
no I was shocked because I follow her on
Instagram and it came up like as she
posted it before it became a big news
story and I was like what's the catch
yeah honestly I think that you should
try and get it 100 and I'll be your
guest
like okay yeah I'll go on a hike if if
Gwyneth requests me to do so yeah you
play Pickleball
yeah I can go on a hike I feel like it's
like a low impact like right back out of
her backyard like easy yeah I think this
is so exciting but I think you're the
right person for it so this is my dream
we'll all rally around you
they must have paid her a lot of money I
wonder how much it's gonna go for
so is it like a bid like an auction I
think so
right that's kind of crazy I don't know
how else would it work
maybe it's like a giveaway like
everybody applies and then one person
gets it I don't think she's gonna
actually charge them to stay at her
house you know no I think that she was
I'm assuming it's going to charity for
like I feel like they would have said
that I just feel like
I feel like it's going to charity
they need to get more details but yeah
is it is this a for-profit kind of thing
there's no it's definitely not for
profit it's definitely for like goop and
Airbnb to how you know marketing but
they're not going to be pocketing the
money I think they'll probably donate it
it sounds like it's getting like mental
health
um I don't think so I think a bunch of
people apply it's like a sweepstakes a
giveaway because if it's like a bid then
it's not gonna be her fans it's going to
be like really wealthy people like
which I guess are her fans but still
like I think that it's gonna be like a
Sweepstake Vibe you know okay
interesting yeah if it was for charity
it certainly would have been in the
caption like all proceeds will be going
to at whatever yeah okay you're probably
right I think so but I still will be
applying you should and you'll take me
along
why why not
well it sounds like it's more like date
night you know you get to have dinner
with her and her husband like I think
you know Ben would probably want to go
you'd have to just fight Ben I'm happy
with that I've been looking for a reason
to fight Ben
no I haven't Ben and I have been getting
along people like think that Ben and I
have beef just because whenever you're
talking negatively about him on the show
like complaining about him I'm always
gassing you up yeah yeah as you should
as I should but no I I do love an adore
Ben yeah there's no beef here and he
probably should go with you okay then I
guess I'll have to apply for myself no I
think we'd have to like go together and
the whole thing would clearly be like an
audition for Gwyneth like we'd be
auditioning like come on the toast maybe
group acquires the toes like maybe she
would be so dazzled by us she'd want to
go like into business with us right also
it kind of has to be me because then
like we're in her guest house we bring
our mics Gwyneth come on the podcast no
not only that we would be like
podcasting even if she doesn't come like
podcasting the whole experience yeah I'm
like vlogging it like it's a work trip
100 and that way if it is about the
highest bid you could write it off
very true it's it's an expense yeah
people act like writing something off
makes it free
and and not people but it's like that's
like the way you talk about it's like
you still have to pay for it you do it's
not free but it
it's like less it's like it's a
beneficial yeah but like you still have
to pay for it
but no you just basically don't pay
taxes on it so it's like kind of half no
you do pay taxes on it
but like you might pay less taxes if you
write enough things off
right like it takes down your overall
income for the year right
so let's buy that by that amount of
money right so less taxes but still
taxes and you still have to pay the sum
I think mathematically yeah I don't know
yeah it depends on like tax brackets and
also what the amount is but like and
where you live
but I would love some numbers I'm like
what you actually how many dollars you
save by writing something off
CPAs sound off in the comments CPAs do
your worst
literally are you ready for our fifth
and final story
is it the story that's brought to you
perchance by skims yes
you guys know we love skims it all
started with their fits everybody
collection of the butteriest underwear
ever so we wanted to try more from the
brand
um we're always seeing their cotton
loungewear all over our feed so I had to
see for ourselves what all the hype was
about and let me tell you they did not
disappoint the cutest and most
flattering sets you'll ever find for in
or out of the house so true I actually
wore like one of the t-shirts to a yeah
a photo shoot the other day
um it was fabulous it was so hot outside
and it was really breathable it fit me
really well it gave me like a nice bust
and skims is just the best they are
creating the next generation of
loungewear for everybody we've been
wearing skims for a really long period
of time and now that we've tried the
cotton collection those matching sets
are the ones that you've probably seen
all over your Instagram they're so cute
we got like the ribbed leggings the
t-shirts the tanks really really cute I
love the briefs too because in the
summer I can't be sleeping in pants and
Ben actually made fun of me the other
day I was like I'm hot he's like well
why do you always sleep in literally a
blazer because I just wear like long
sleeves and pants and ever since I got
the briefs from the cotton collection
they're so light they're perfect to
sleep in
um after all the hype skims is truly
truly worth it and you just don't want
to be missing out because like all the
cool kids are wearing skims and you
should probably do the same so the
cotton t-shirt from skims is the best
also the entire cotton collection has
been all over Instagram for so long and
once we finally caved we were Obsessed
the bone material is like so on Trend
right now that's what I got a lot of my
pieces in the cotton Jersey t-shirt is
the one I wore the video shoot in the
color bone
um it's their most tagged collection
it's made with a classic cotton fabric
it's really comfortable it's available
in sizes extra extra small to 4X so
believe the Hypes Kim says over a
hundred thousand five star review for
reasons the cotton collection and more
are available now at skims.com you can
also get free shipping on orders over 75
so after you place your order be sure to
let them know that the toe sent you
select podcast in the survey and select
the toast in the drop down menu that
follows today's episode is also brought
to you by Athena club which is perfect
timing because last night I finally
shaved my legs after two weeks in the
shower with my Athena Club razor the
blade on my old razor used to get really
goopy after a few years is but we love
the water activated serum on the Athena
Club razor there's just enough of it to
soothe while shaving but it never gets
gunky on the blade my old razor also
used to fall off the holder all the time
like it would literally wake me up in
the middle of the night that whole thing
came crashing down it's so scary the
Athena Club one I've had on four months
it does not move
after the first few shaves with my old
razor
um it just never used to feel super
clean like it was shaving really well
um I have zero razor bumps after using
the Athena Club razor and I've been now
on the fina Club train for like six
months it's designed with built-in skin
guards to help prevent razor burn while
being gentle on curves plus the razor
blade is surrounded by a water activated
Serum with shea butter and hyaluronic
acid the best part is that the razor kit
is only ten dollars it comes with two
blade heads a magnetic hook for shower
storage and your choice of handle color
the handle color options are super cute
but they even have black and white
razors if you're just like more of a
minimalist I have it in pink
um the blade refills are fabulous
because you never have to think about it
you don't have to get like some crusty
Dusty Rusty razor you just have your
replacement blade shipped to you and you
can find them now in Target stores
nationwide so it's so easy easy to swing
by one of the many Target locations and
get your blades they have the most
amazing shaving foam as well that will
leave your skin soft skin like using a
shaving cream or shaving foam is so
underrated the Athena Club one is
amazing so switch to the better razor
and show your skin you care Within Club
get started today by shopping in store
at Target stores nationwide just head to
the Shaving aisle to find the Razor kit
Cloud shave foam wax strips and razor
refills again available at Targets
Nationwide
thank you Claudia you're welcome our
fifth and final story a little new mama
news Jessie J is a new mama she said she
doesn't want to go back to her pre-baby
figure so Jessie J's embracing her body
after the birth of her son on Tuesday
the singer and mom to her
three-month-old son Skye responded to
people commenting on her post-baby
figure in a candid note shared on her
Instagram story she said a couple of
people have said to me I bet you can't
wait to get your body back my reply is I
don't want to go back that body is gone
I want my body to go forward I'm getting
my body forward that's the vibe ladies
so I actually just started following
Jessie J a few weeks ago when I saw that
she had her baby and this woman loves
being a mother so much it is such a joy
to watch she gets like so
excited about ever like she just has
such a positive mentality I think she
tried for a really long time to have a
baby I think we reported some news about
her in the last few years that like she
was struggling and it is such a pleasure
to watch someone who just absolutely
loves being a mom and I love her
mentality and like she is back in the
gym like she's working out but she's not
like trying to bounce back like I just
like how she is embracing everything
yeah I mean I'd be curious to hear your
thoughts on this because I've never had
a baby and like I feel like there's a
lot of hate on bounce back culture which
I agree with but I think if somebody
wants to bounce back really quickly like
that's on them like everybody can make
their own choices I don't think we need
to hate on one another but like we
certainly don't need to be asking people
like when are you getting back in the
gym like are you ready to get back to
your pre-baby body
yeah I agree like we don't need to be
asking people everyone can make their
own choice I have no issue with bounce
back culture and also sometimes it is
like very
uh aspirational and inspiring to see
someone who who's able to bounce back
really quickly I think it's really
genetics it's how you carry it it's like
you know some people have their baby and
then their body like a few weeks later
looks maybe underneath their clothes it
looks different but like to the
untrained eye it looks the same and
that's not the truth for everyone but it
is kind of nice to know that it's like
not this most destructive process and
that like right you can
feel like yourself again relatively soon
but that also might make other people
feel bad
not that it doesn't make me feel bad I'm
just like oh that's cool nice for her
gold jealous jealous but okay
yeah no it's not like on other people to
make someone else like somebody's
decision about their body like if that
impacts you like that sucks but it's not
on them to make decisions about their
life so as not to like impact another
person yeah and like some people
actively are like I'm snapping back and
they're working really hard and and
that's cool but there are also some
people who like don't seem like they're
have to work as hard in just their body
kind of naturally bounces back and I
just think that's genetics that's like
me being upset that I wasn't born a
supermodel like okay right no and that's
why like comparison should like you
should never compare yourself to other
people because there are so many things
about like bodies especially like
postpartum that are truly out of your
control whether it's like genetics or
just the circumstances of like your
situation yeah socio-economic Factor so
like you really just shouldn't ever
compare yourself to anyone's Journey
because everyone is different even just
like getting stretch marks like you
there's no Rhyme or a reason really for
like
people who get them it's not like you
reach a certain threshold and you have
them like some people say smaller but
they have them some people are bigger
and they don't have them like it just it
is what it is and there's no sense in
like
spending so much time harping on it and
I just I think it's nice to have people
like Jessie J Who are just like very
positive about the whole thing she her
social media contents and she's had a
baby has definitely come across my desk
and she's truly like a joy she sings to
her baby so much and she seems so happy
and we spoke for years like she was very
open about her journey
um with her fertility and I think she
tried really hard to have a baby with
Channing Tatum like so to see somebody
after all those years like be in this
place it's really a joy to watch yeah
and there is so much content now you
know about the realities of motherhood
and yeah the negatives and the things
that are like tired which is also good
but I just really like when you can see
someone who's like just absolutely
loving it and I think that that's really
positive message yeah I sent you one of
her videos she was like singing to her
baby in a parking garage yeah um that's
you
literally and she also has the most
amazing voice like it must be such a
pleasure to one sing for your baby and
for her baby to hear that no totally
it's like a symphony of sounds she's
really talented yeah like sometimes I'll
even be playing like with Harry's
musical instruments and I have like the
basics but like and then I think about
like how Luke Combs probably plays on
like Texas little guitar he's playing
whole ass songs no it's true like the
babies are so lucky yeah it's pretty
cool
it's pretty cool so those are the fast
five stories feel as though you needed
to know them good ones true true good
ones and we're not done yet because it's
Wednesday dear toasters our weekly
advice segment every Wednesday we take
three submissions from you guys about
things that you're going through and we
do our best to give you know good good
advice good old-fashioned advice
sometimes
um if you ever want to submit it's
totally Anonymous there are two ways to
submit the first is if you go to the
toastpodcast.com there's a submission
box when you scroll down it just says
Dear toasters it's totally Anonymous you
can also just shoot us an email dear
toasters gmail.com and we're gonna do
our best to help the girlies through
whatever it is they're going through yes
we are we're going to do our worst
Claudia this one is actually perfect
timing based on the conversation we had
about like money men and Reba
so hey Jackson Claude I need some
serious advice back in January I opened
up a credit card and added my boyfriend
as an authorized user over the course of
the past six months he has racked up
around forty thousand dollars of debt on
this card he insisted that everything
was going to be taken care of every time
I asked last month the card was canceled
due to the outstanding debt after the
card being canceled my credit score took
a massive hit from the delinquent
balance my boyfriend finally claimed
came clean that he would not be able to
pay it he is now taken out a loan to pay
it my immediate reaction to the
dishonesty was that I needed to break up
with him but I'm having a hard time
doing this because everything else about
our relationship has been perfect
healthy and happy we're both 25 we've
recently been having serious talks about
moving in together in the next year I'm
worried if that we stay together the
future we planned is not going to be
possible because of his situation as
well as being able to build back the
trust what should I do okay this is
really tough and I mean it is it's
what's done is done but what were you
doing putting your boyfriend on your
credit card
yeah I I didn't want to like blame you
at first but like this is some lessons
you really have to be like learning the
hard way and this is like your financial
security especially as a woman like is
so important and this is like something
I'm sure you will never do again because
you were burned so badly and to be
honest like of all the things that I
would be mad at like yeah the dishonesty
is and the lying is like is frustrating
but it's not even the number one thing
here I feel like the number one thing is
this person is clearly like not
financially literate yet and you're only
25 and like that these things do take
time and you have to like learn some
things the hard way but
um I just wouldn't
it's not like like it's
bigger than the dead it's like a
judgment issue and also it's not like a
one-time purchase of forty thousand
dollars oops I made a mistake it's like
a rolling snowballing thing that he
continued to do over and over again with
your name
to me it's like yes your other your
relationship is good otherwise but this
signals a whole host of issues like just
disrespect like
the fact that he would like knowingly
make his problem now your problem you're
the one with like collections probably
calling you you're the one whose credit
takes a hit like that to me is worse
than the dishonesty it's the way he was
so willing to throw you and your
financial stability under the bus like
that is not a person who like deeply
cares about you honestly I agree and but
now if he has all this debt you guys are
talking about moving in together it
sounds like he doesn't have his life
together you guys might be taking steps
that you are not ready for and he might
just be like getting you excited about
all those things in order I don't know
maybe to get on your next credit card
too like
this is such a red flag to do as a
boyfriend like when you are partners and
committed whether it's engaged or
married like eventually you will merge
finances but that takes time and trust
and I don't like this
I don't like this either and it's in
zero way your fault but I think there
are valuable lessons that you can take
from here too like your financial
security whether you're in a
relationship or not is of utmost
importance and you know you're obviously
like a really trusting person and you
probably are awesome but sometimes being
so trusting is the thing that gets you
in trouble because you just love so you
know people take advantage of you and
the fact that you have your partnered
your boyfriend would be the one to take
advantage of the person that's supposed
to like have your back protect you and
protect you like that just does not bode
well for the relationship so it's up to
you you know you're we don't see what's
going on in the day-to-day you know him
better than we do I don't know what the
Forty thousand dollars was spent on but
the idea that he just like was racking
up charges on your credit card not
giving a care in the world about what it
would mean for you would really [__]
piss me off
yeah and there's a Litany of things that
could have happened here but I do think
it's worth exploring if this person has
a gambling problem because this does
kind of sound like that like to open up
credit cards to like you know to venmo
Bookies like boys love to like bet on
Sports and stuff I feel like there might
be more underneath the 40K because what
the hell is he doing you know like right
what did he spend 40K on that he didn't
have the money
for and saying saying that he's gonna
you know pay it back no problem it's
like oh yeah I have a parlay or whatever
they call it coming in and I'll be able
to pay this off like let me just charge
another thousand it does kind of sound
like maybe a little bit of like a
gambling situation that's a very good
point
and also like now he's taken out a loan
to pay off his debt
which is worse but like but you know
what like [__] his fight but that's yeah
that's his thing but now you're talking
about moving in together so now becomes
your thing again and what if he can't
get uh you know a line of credit or a
mortgage then it it's all going to fall
to you because you're the one who has
good credit I do worry though that like
if she breaks up with him like he's like
all right why the [__] would I pay this
[__] back like I never have to see her
again well I think you need to get your
money like she said he got he took the
loan
you need to get the the credit card paid
off in full and then I really think you
need to break up with him honestly like
this is now that I've really talked it
through this is not a person who cares
about you like and of course as all
things are like this is gendered so to
like [__] up a woman's financial future
is [__] like I'm mad yeah I agree and
there's just not enough like I don't
know how long you guys have been dating
for it you're 25 it can't be that long
there's just not enough like history to
try and like work through this enormous
betrayal like I see you thank you for
the lesson good day sir yeah is how I
feel I agree like this is egregious
yeah egregious
our next one is different it's like a
little funny okay okay hey swirly
girlies my husband has an identical twin
when they say the twins have crazy close
bonds nothing compares to my husband and
his twin brother we vacation together we
live right next door to him and his
family we are together every chance we
get I swear they have their own language
and I wouldn't be surprised if they can
hear each other each other's thoughts
but for the most part it's great
family's so important to me we've been
together for over a decade and we are
all extremely close however a couple of
weeks ago and a couple of drinks in we
started of course talking about each
other dying my husband and his twin were
saying that they both would save each
other before me and my sister-in-law and
of course I was upset we started arguing
back and they said we just didn't
understand their bond and they would
literally die without one another am I
being a [__] since then it's literally
all I can think about and it's kind of
hurting my feelings should I bring it up
again or just let it go she's his wife
yeah no like I understand why she's
upset you should be your husband's
number one person in the world but like
listen those two they came into the
world together they are going out
together you I can't you can't even like
fathom the problem is is that they
answered honestly when they should have
just like said the right thing but they
know but it's like go back to what
realistically you're not realistically
going to be in a situation where your
twin brother and your wife are both
hanging off the ledge of a bridge and
you can only save one so it's like a
hypothetical situation situation but I
know what she means like you want to be
your partner's number one priority and I
can't really speak to this because I am
not a twin and I don't know that
situation like what that what's that
what that's like well I think a lot of
twins are very bonded but these seem
like the extreme and I mean if you look
at I was I get all of these videos of
like babies in the womb now and I saw
the cutest video of these two twins who
didn't know they were born yet their
heads were like underwater not their
nose and mouth but they thought they
were still in the amniotic attack and
they're holding on the way that they are
in the womb for 10 months they are
hugging each other the entire time it
and we've seen three identical strangers
it is a bond that is beyond anything
else the problem is they should have
just said like oh yeah you're our number
ones but I know privately that your
husband his number one person in the
world is his twin and I do think that
that is okay
but he should have just answered the
question in a way that would make you
feel better it's like yesterday with
Bebe rexa like he should have just said
you look good
so let's say he wasn't a twin and this
was his brother and he basically said
like my number one priority always is
gonna be my brother but you're second
you're so close like what do you say
then
I'm a little less understanding no uh oh
guys it depends on their relationship
honestly like
the bond that they're talking about like
because if I look at their relationship
and I'm like wait that's more important
to you than our relationship well then
what do we have but if it's like I don't
know
by the way I don't know if this girl has
kids with him yet because she talked
about the the twin has a family and kids
um but like
you know a wife is so important but a
wife and who's also the mother of your
children obviously takes it to another
level so like maybe you would take
number one spot once you have kids I
don't know maybe I just think that
regardless the crime is that he didn't
say you
yeah of course what goes on in his heart
is his own private thoughts and feelings
I don't know how you reconcile this
honestly because like Ben ever said that
I wasn't his number one like seriously
like I would Riot like I would be so mad
like there's not allowed to be anyway
but that's also because because you know
Benning you know that there's no one in
his life he has a closer relationship
with within you so if he said one of
those other people he'd be like what I
like that's not even that strong of a
relationship compared to what we have
but if Ben had someone
who was like his other half
well one I think it would affect your
relationship that's true but it is what
it is it sounds like they have a
perfectly lovely relationship
um it would just be shocking for Ben
because like there's no one even comes
close to number two it's the yeah yeah
yeah you know
yeah okay now that you like have a
family like what are supposed to be like
what is Zach's number one priority
should be you or Harry so people argue
about this like not people
um thinkers and you know reals because
some people say it should be your
partner should be your number one and
then there are other people who say that
your kids should be your number one what
do you think
I feel that like I don't
I love my like
no you think the kid yeah
of course like the kid needs you to walk
like yeah I agree and I think in making
our kids our priority we're also making
each other our prayer it's our family of
course of course and what you should
neglect the kid like no I agree yeah no
but P like this isn't a constantly two
schools there are two schools of thought
yes because some people think if you
don't prioritize your partner as number
one that that affects your kids too like
then you know it's best for your it's
best for your kids if your partner is
number one true
I don't know that's a good question I
didn't realize I was stumbling into like
such a philosophical debate yeah no it's
it's very layered as most things are
yeah
all right are you ready for a third and
final so I would just tell her to uh you
know he loves you to give advice he
loves you listen go watch some videos of
twins in utero it can't be explained
it can't be it's it's like a biological
phenomenon oh and it was a hypothetical
question and this is why I don't like
dumb [__] games it's true that's we
must keep into perspective it was a
hypothetical question there's literally
like the most point zero zero zero zero
one percent chance that he's ever in a
situation where he has to save either
you or him like for real right and the
good news is your husband is honest to a
fault
finding the Silver Lining yes
all right third and final hey girlies
longtime toe store been a stand since
the breath I've been seeing this guy
who's a total page on things have been
going really well except for one thing
he doesn't like when my dog gets on the
bed during sex he loves dogs has his own
dog but his dog doesn't get on the
furniture or the bed at all I have a
small Pooch who's a big cuddler she's
allowed in my furniture she spoons with
me every night in bed she also likes to
be right next to me when I'm having sex
and she just stares it's weird but I've
gotten used to it over the years she
doesn't get involved she doesn't like
lick make her you know but her presence
is known this is making the guy I'm
seeing really uncomfortable he nicely
will ask if the dog can move when we're
getting steaming I've tried putting my
dog in the bathroom with Treats but she
head butts the door open and ends up
jumping on the bed while the deed is
happening what do I do to keep my dog
off where do the stress Bros go during
sexy time do I need to move her any help
would be great well I feel like the
difference here is is that like with
Theo and Bruno they were you know family
no they were brought into our family
as you know we were already married or
Ben and I had been together for four
years like this is technically like your
dog and he has his own dog like he
probably doesn't feel like you know it's
not his daughter you know Theo is our
son like hands down so we and I will be
honest like Theo is almost always in the
bed when we're having sex we have a
king-sized bed like he doesn't really
he's sleeping like he doesn't even care
yeah you know what so the crate training
is a good point too the crate training
is a good point because what for a
really long like now it just depends but
a lot of times we put Bruno in the crate
like we're kind of with I'm with this
girl like sometimes it can be disruptive
and it's like weird and if we know that
things are going that way like we'll put
Bruno in the crate and then we take him
out but he's very he's fine in the crate
he's not head butting the door and so he
has a safe place to go and it's totally
fine so I understand why your boyfriend
feels this way I think you need to um
do a little more to
yeah he's totally justified and it's not
like he lets his dog on the bed and not
yours like it's just a no dog thing
which I actually I get like and even the
times where Bruno where we don't put him
away like
we're very aware he's there and it's
weird and besides sex like there are
other things your dog like just might
need to be put away for like when our
exterminator comes and sprays it you
know needs to dry before Sofia doesn't
like lick up all the you know repellent
they're like life situations where a
crate or any sort of like confined space
for a dog are actually really necessary
so it might just behulu for all
different reasons to either crate train
or get him like a you know a little
puppy gate something yeah but it might
be late in his life to start that like
you kind of have to start it young but
you do need to find a little bit of a
solution or you need to compromise yeah
because it doesn't sound like your dog
is like a Theo at the end of the bed
like he's just like there watching yeah
in the way
yeah yeah yeah no but it's definitely
like a thing like sometimes Theo will
like get up out of his sleep and like
come lay next to us because he always
loves to like have a warm body next to
him when he's laying and it's like you
actually can't do that right now Theo
like [__] off and we'll just like put
him on the floor no it's definitely a
thing and we definitely put Bruno away a
lot
considering like you know he's
you know mommy's Angel part of the
family sleeps in the bed with us but
like yeah we're that's just us
I can't believe there are people who
have dogs who don't let the dogs sleep
in bed with them like that's what's the
[__] point who didn't sleep with us
until
Harry was um sleep trained
okay but he was like a puppy at first
he's only two yeah oh my God his
birthday's coming up mommy's King kill
me no I'm excited to celebrate him he
deserves it when's his big day August
15th oh it's soon should we throw him
with like a little pirate party a little
potty his cousins can come cute hell
about all the crew from the dog walking
group oh my God yes
yeah no because first he was a baby so
he was crate trained like in he'd
learned to sleep in the crate
then Harry was a baby so he's not gonna
sleep with us like with a newborn in the
bed
and then once Harry started sleeping
through the night you know and also once
we moved to Florida and we got a king
bed because first we had a queen bed
then we're like you know what because I
always say like 8 A.M to 8 PM's Harry
o'clock 8 P.M to 8 A.M it's strikes
o'clock and it can't be sure it's
o'clock if he's not sleeping with us 100
and he's just become such a doll in the
bed so our advice here is you know
compromise he's not entirely wrong for
asking yeah I yeah that is my advice it
can be done and that's our show ladies
and gentlemen I'm starving you know my
back is broken I've gotta pee always
could use a snack
thank you guys so much for listening to
The Chosen Monday Morning Show where we
deliver the past five stories that you
need to know every Monday through Friday
so if you're watching this one no every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so if
you're watching this on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
to podcasts I know our podcast can be
found on Spotify iTunes judge Republic
video I already castbox all the places
so maybe listen to podcasts find us the
toasty five star review about a
beautiful standing
get intelligent we are have an amazing
day and we'll see you tomorrow love ya
bye